Así es pues vamos a destacar esos esa
victoria de seis goles por uno entre
Portugal y Suiza con Pues un hombre que
se estrenó hoy con la camiseta de
Portugal se trata de Gonzalo Ramos quien
entró a sustituyendo a Cristiano Ronaldo
en este partido titular fue titular
desde el comienzo y marcó un triplete
hubo también goles de Pepe se alzó por
toda encima de la de la Barrera para
poder marcar de cabeza gol de Guerrero
en un excelente jugada colectiva y fue
rafaelado el el encargado ya de poner
ese gol en número seis en la marcadora
kanji por parte de Suiza Pues fue el que
pudo digamos salvar la partida de los
suizos marcando ese único gol ya sobre
el minuto 58 y pues Portugal que mostró
que era muy fácil poder llegar en todo
caso a vencer la portería la portería
Suiza muy pragmáticos muy buenos en sus
acciones ofensivas también en el
contraataque y pues los suizos que de
ellos no se vio nada muy diferente al
partido que habían ofrecido antes ante
Serbia y que los había permitido les
había permitido clasificarse a esta
ronda